AS MANY OF US KNOW, THE TYPICAL
AMERICAN DIET IS RICH IN
ESSENTIAL POISONS.
AS EVIDENCE MOUNTS THAT BIG AGRA
AND THE FOOD LOBBY
HAVE TURNED OUR FOOD SUPPLY
INTO AN ADDICTIVE, FATTENING
DEATH MENU OF ARTIFICIAL
CHEMICALS, ANTIBIOTICS AND
COOL RANCH CARCINOGENS.
THE QUESTION IS NOW THAT WE HAVE
THIS KNOWLEDGE, NOW THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF
THIS, WHAT ARE FOOD COMPANIES
GOING TO DO ABOUT IT?
>> LITTLE CAESAR'S CREATED THE
NEW BACON WRAPPED DEEP, DEEP
DISH PIZZA TOPPED WITH PEPPERONI
AND BACON AND WRAPPED
IN OVER THREE AND A HALF
FEET OF BACON!
>> Jon: IT APPEARS THEY'RE
GOING TO SAY (BLEEP) YOU ANYWAY.
(LAUGHTER)
SCREW YOUR HEALTH STUDY!
LITTLE CAESAR'S WILL WRAP THAT
STUDY IN BACON, BATTER IT,
DEEP FRY IT AND FEED IT THROUGH
YOUR ANUS WITH A 32-OUNCE SODA.
(LAUGHTER)
THE LAST PART IS, IF YOU HAVE
THE COUPON.
(LAUGHTER)
THE I DON'T GIVE A (BLEEP)
APPROACH IS GETTING A LOT OF
TRACTION IN THE A FAST FOOD
COMMUNITY.
>> WHAT COULD BE BETTER THAN
GOLDEN CORRAL'S PIPING HOT
DELICIOUS YEAST ROLLS?
HOW ABOUT SIX FREE YEAST ROLLS
TO TAKE HOME!
>> COTTON CANDY AND THE
CHOCOLATE WONDER-FALL.
BOTH PART OF OUR ENDLESS BUFFET.
>>EVERY ROUND OF FRIDAY'S
ENDLESS APPS COULD BE A
DIFFERENT ENDLESS APP.
>> OLIVE GARDEN'S NEW BUY ONE,
TAKE ONE, GO FOR DINNER TONIGHT
AND TAKE HOME A SECOND ENTREE
FOR LATER.
>> Jon: LATER?
YOU WENT THERE FOR DINNER!
ARE YOU WORRIED YOU WILL GET
LIGHTHEADED UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SPARE DINNER FOR THE RIDE HOME?
WHICH OLIVE GARDEN ARE YOU GOING
TO?
YOU CAN CHOOSE ONE THAT'S CLOSE
TO YOU!
AND ISN'T SUCH A FAR DRIVE THAT
YOU NEED A SECOND DINNER!
THERE'S ALMOST AS MANY OLIVE
GARDENS AS THERE ARE STARBUCKS!
IDEA FOR A BUSINESS, COMBO PASTA
AND COFFEE CHAIN RESTAURANT,
OLIVE BUCKS.
FEATURED MENU ITEM, THE VENTI
ROSEMARY MOCHA ALFREDO,
3,000 CALORIES OF "OH, MY GOD...
BUT, WHILE SOME --
IT REALLY MAKES ME FEEL LIKE
HOMER SIMPSON.
WHILE SOME ESTABLISHMENTS
ARE GIVING OUR OBESITY
CRISIS A CHUBBY MIDDLE FINGER,
OTHERS ARE MORE CONFLICTED
ABOUT THEIR ROLE.
HERE'S McDONALD'S IN JANUARY.
>> ALL VEGETARIANS, FOODIES AND
GASTRONAUTS KINDLY AVERT
YOUR EYES.
YOU CAN'T GET JUICINESS LIKE
THIS FROM SOY OR QUINOA.
THIS IS NOT GREEK YOGURT, NOR
WILL THAT EVER BE KALE.
>> Jon: HEY, WE CLEAR, YOU FOODY
(BLEEP)S?
THE ONLY KALE MCDONALD'S WILL
EVER SERVE IS TO THE CHICKEN
WHOSE ANUS GOES IN YOUR
McNUGGETS!
BUT THEN IN MARCH, MCDONALD'S
DOES THIS.
>> McDONALD'S TRYING TO OFFER
HEALTHIER FARE TO ITS CUSTOMERS.
THIS LAST WEEK EXECUTIVES
ANNOUNCED THE U.S. RESTAURANTS
WILL STOP SELLING CHICKEN
RAISED WITH ANTIBIOTICS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
>> Jon: CHICKEN WITHOUT
ANTIBIOTICS?
WELL, NOW I'M CONFLICTED.
I WANT HEALTHIER FOOD, BUT
I'LL MISS TREATING MY EAR
INFECTIONS WITH THE BUFFALO
RANCH McCHICKEN.
(LAUGHTER)
AND THE MAKING -- EW,
THAT'S HALFWAY IN THERE -- AND
THE MAKING FOOD SLIGHTLY LESS
BAD FOR YOU CRAZE IS SPREADING.
>> DUNKIN' DONUTS ELIMINATING
THE CHEMICAL USED TO GIVE
POWDERED DOUGHNUTS THAT
BRIGHT WHITE LOOK.
>> Jon: I'M NOT A CHEF...
BUT I THOUGHT THE THING THAT
GAVE THOSE DONUTS THE BRIGHT
WHITE LOOK WAS POWDERED SUGAR!
BUT WHAT IF A COMPANY WANTS
THE POSITIVE P.R. OF GOING
HEALTHY BUT DOESN'T WANT
THE HASSLE OF ACTUALLY
IMPROVING THEIR PRODUCT. WELL
THERE'S A SOLUTION FOR THEM TOO.
>> WE DO WANT TO MOVE TO A NEW
KIDS EAT RIGHT LABEL THAT WILL
SOON BE APPEARING ON
KRAFT SINGLES FROM THE
ACADEMY OF NUTRITION
AND DIETETICS.
>> Jon: WHY?
HERE'S HOW YOU KNOW KRAFT HAS
NOT CHANGED THEIR INGREDIENTS.
KRAFT IS STILL NOT LEGALLY
ALLOWED TO CALL THIS PRODUCT
"CHEESE."
HOW YOU MIGHT WONDER DID KRAFT
SINGLES MANAGE TO WRANGLE A KIDS
EAT RIGHT LABEL?
>> THE ACADEMY HAS A PROGRAM
CALLED KIDS EAT RIGHT.
THEY ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT
WITH KRAFT WHERE KRAFT
IS HELPING SUPPORT THIS. THEY'RE
GIVING MONEY TO THE ACADEMY
TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM AND IN
EXCHANGE THEY
GET TO PUT THIS LABEL ON THEIR
PRODUCTS.
>> SO KRAFT IS PAYING THE
ACADEMY --
>> Jon: THAT SOUNDS REASONABLE.
TURNS OUT THE ACADEMY OF
DIETETICS IS AN ACADEMY IN THE
SAME WAY THIS IS CHEESE.
AT THIS POINT WE SHOULD JUST
STOP TRYING WITH THE HEALTHY
STUFF AND EMBRACE WHO WE
REALLY ARE AND PERHAPS START
WITH THE BEACON
OF FREEDOM WHO DREW SO MANY OF
OUR ANCESTORS HERE WITH THOSE
FAMOUS WORDS -- GIVE ME YOUR
THAI FOOD, YOUR PORK CHOPS, YOUR
HUNGRY MASSES, YEARNING TO
BREATHE HEAVILY.